alo alo
bạn nghe thấy mình nghỉ khó đúng không
bộ không biết rồi các bạn nghe rõ không
có gì à mày
cho tôi bảo với tôi sẽ dùng tay ngay
chùm thì tôi sẽ không nghe được giọng
Tôi thấy cậu không biết được âm lượng
người to hay nhỏ như nào cả
có gì Các bạn cứ bảo tôi nha
thôi nếu mọi người để ý thấy thôi Có
phải giọng có phải ổn hơn hôm trước
trước về ốm không có mai thì á
Hôm Qua đây cực kì ốm hôm nay tự nhiên
lại thấy
buồn hơn khá nhiều rồi
sao và có dẫn hơi ngạc nhiên khi tôi
biết được các cô bị có biết
đây là bị lần đầu thôi vẫn tôi không hả
nào tớ nghĩ là mình sẽ bất tử với kiểu
là không ngờ bị
cho dù là tôi ở nhà khá nhiều ít khi ra
ngoài ra ngoài khi mà kiểu có dịp thì ra
ngoài không phải chủ yếu ở nhà - Play là
phải ở tầm vài tuần có ai rủ đi chơi thì
ra ngoài mình đi chơi sau đó thì cũng về
nhà ở trong nhà suốt thôi
em là thành viên mới
của gái xinh chọn lọc à Tại sao không
lên đây làm đi
nhầm thành hai có hai bay bụng không
cũng hơi lâng lâng một tí bởi vì à
Ông có biết là cảm giác mà hiểu mấy ngày
không được cái phạm đâu
có biết nghĩ rồi không tắm nhưng mà hôm
nay khi vừa mới xong xong rồi tôi thử
tắm khô
thì có vẻ là nó dễ chịu hơn về băng Lâm
ờ ờ
tôi cũng xin tất cả lời luôn cái câu mà
tôi vừa đọc nhầm có hai bay không thôi
tôi một con người à nghiêm túc nhất tốc
Thủy cũng không hẳn tôi cứ kiểu nửa nạc
nửa mỡ Hiểu không
bia không hút thuốc Nói chung ở không
nói cho hành nghiêm túc về mấy khoản đấy
nhưng mà rủ tôi đi chơi gì tôi sẽ là
chơi kiểu là đi nhậu thì tôi rửa mồi nãy
đi hát karaoke với khác này
nhảy ba bụng thôi Sẵn sàng đi mỗi không
Không uống đi rồi nên là
nó cũng kiểu hơi hư Nhược rủ tôi rồi tôi
dụ là chủ tôi đi chơi qua đêm nè đi đi
đâu đấy xa a ấy sắp đi hết
một phần là do cái ngành của tôi khá
thoải mái với công công việc các thứ thứ
có vẻ là
thoải mái thành ra tôi mới tự do như thế
nhiều người kiểu không không được như
thế là đã thấy vừa tự do lại vừa có phải
chính nữa nên là nó cũng thoải mái thích
đi đâu Mình thích làm gì cũng được á tự
do thoải mái mấy hôm nay nhỏ Vì tôi bảo
đấy thì tôi đang đeo cốt để mà nếu thấy
nhỏ
để đợi tôi tí đợi tôi chuyển luôn à
anh Alo ạ Bây giờ tôi chưa Tôi thấy nó
còn chạm ngưỡng là vạch đỏ rồi sao to
đúng không ạ Alo alo alo
bởi vì a Kiểu cái
Ừ cái kia con tai nghe trùm mà nó là nó
tai nghe trùm nó vừa tai nghe vừa có cả
một tí mic
tôi từng cho bé uống xe Vậy mày có ba
bốn trăm nghìn thôi mày chung là tôi lấy
từ trên công ty về để mà dùng kiểu Vừa
nhai
Anh vừa nghe vừa có tím
à còn à
khi dùng hẳn con Mic riêng với một con
tay ngay riêng
mình đang dạy webforge với bác em hả
ở hiện tại thì mình chú trọng về bác em
hơn con em thì mình chỉ làm mình chỉ các
bạn cách để lấy giao diện về thôi a đấy
tôi sẽ chia sẻ Tôi quên mất là tôi sẽ
chia sẻ cho các bạn về cài right có
template sau
một chút đó là
thì tại sao mình lại chọn việc dạy học
Ờ Ờ
hôm trước có mà bạn hỏi bảo là
ừ ừ
các bạn thích ở bạn đam mê rồi đam mê
công nghệ tin ở chọn đúng ngành cùng em
Tin làm các thứ thứ Ừ thì cũng hay khi
mà
em thích cái ngành này sao mà làm được
đúng có sự hữu thì nó hay mà
Ừ nhưng mà
gì để nói về đam mê công nghệ thông tin
thì sẽ K là cũng
anh không hả là chuẩn lắm Thực ra thì
tôi
đam mê khá nhiều thứ khá nhiều thứ không
phải mỗi 0mg đâu
cho tôi
tôi nói với ông ở tôi chuyên cả luật cả
chính trị cả hồi đẹp nhé
vật lý Nói chung là tôi chuyên khá nhiều
môn - môn Văn rồi ở Bảo môn Hóa nữa môn
Văn bởi vì a mình không ngờ theo sách
giáo khoa cô dạy
nêu cảm nhận của em thức ra toàn cảm
nhận của cô ấy muốn Hóa thì nó là ngôn
ngữ ngoài hành tinh nổi rồi
môn mấy cái môn về nghệ thuật thì giống
nhiều âm nhạc Mỹ thuật thì chắc chịu
thể dục cũng chịu này
ờ ờ
anh như tòa đại hội những cái muốn khác
kể cả môn Lịch sử Địa lý về tội khá giỏi
tôi được 10 phải sự 10 phẩy địa lý anh á
bạn từng Suýt đi
Ừ tôi ở trong cái đội gọi là cũng gọi là
trong đội để ạ
khi luyện để mà đi thi học sinh giỏi
từng ở ở cả môn Vật Lý môn Toán này môn
sinh này
Ừ nếu tôi khá chuyên nhiều với môn đấy
Tại sao gọi ở chuyên chỉ đơn giản là
mình thích học cái môn đấy thôi mình
thấy học mấy môn đấy nó hay cho dù Thầy
Cô có thể chạy không hay nhưng tôi vẫn
biết được cái môn này hay vì tôi có ngồi
đọc sách giáo khoa còn rất nhiều người
khác thì không nên hãy cho tôi thấy hay
a cho tôi không tự tin là tôi giỏi đâu
rồi kìa tôi từng gặp rất nhiều người
giỏi hai con nhà người ta hơn tôi rồi à
anh không thành tích học tập của tôi
không hẳn là tốt làm đâu Hồi ở mọi cấp 3
tôi chỉ học sinh trung bình thôi tất cả
tháng năm học sinh mình có 5 con shit
shit không đi học sinh trung bình Nếu mà
ám chỉ tôi là tôi khá là thích mấy cái
môn đấy mới học hồi cấp 2 tôi học còn
liên quan đến vì thành tích một tí về
hồi đấy à Cậu phải phải có bằng học sinh
giỏi mới được cộng điểm cộng ấy mấy ông
hiểu còn à
Em còn ở lên cấp 3 thì cho ra là nó
không quan trọng về điểm số nữa không Em
hãy để tôi học kiểu dạng mà tôi không
quan tâm để thành tích đâu bài tập về
nhà thôi Cũng chả mời về lạ là nghe Tôi
không phải là con nhà người ta sôi chị
học ở trên lớp tôi về nhà tù ngồi chơi
với phương châm của tôi ngồi ôn thi đại
học của tôi tôi còn chẳng Ôn Hà Nội theo
hư quá như là nói chung là tôi Chị Ôm
vài tháng cuối nên hai a thu mới Trượt
đại học tôi không hẳn nó là các bạn đừng
hãy như tôi nhưng mà ý tôi là tôi học
đúng nghĩa là
Đó là kiểu dạng là ở
khoa học để hiểu học và để mình cảm thấy
hay rồi nó chứ không có gì gò bó đây cả
May mà kiểu khá thoải mái ở vụ đấy
sao tự như tôi rồi nói quà kìa cái việc
học tôi thế bởi vì a từ cái việc học tôi
học khá ổn mấy môn như thế này nha tôi
có đam mê khá nhiều ngày tôi đã đam mê
về cả ngành báo lại vì tôi muốn tự do
ngôn luận này nếu với cùng chuyển nhận
ra là thứ nhất là phải giỏi văn từ ai là
không được tự do ngôn luận không được
nêu cảm nghĩ không phải nghĩ gì được
phép nói lấy ở trên báo chí
Ừ thế thôi trưởng phải làm chim nữa
thứ hai đó là tôi định làm à kiến trúc
sư Hồi đấy Không bia là hồi đấy Tự chat
tôi kể với ông ấy vụ này rồi còn để tôi
từ nhà
Ừ ok béo về vụ Tôi muốn làm kiến trúc sư
gì nhỉ rồi tôi con này chia sẻ cái điều
thầm kín đấy cho cái bạn à Bạn yêu đơn
phương hồi cấp 2 rồi tự toàn lỡ nói nhầm
một câu chuyện
ạ Bạn ấy không nhớ em à mấy béo nghe vụ
này chưa nhỉ ra tôi từng kể cái vụ này
hai ba lần rồi không nhớ đã từng nói với
ông chưa thôi
Chị Trang ơi ở lớp trưởng trao người xem
nhiều nhất thì chả chưa đúng không
à à
anh chị đấy giờ lấy chồng chưa ạ ha ha
em có con hơn 1 hơn 2 tuổi rồi thì phải
ạ
giỏi vẽ tao không hả Chưa đúng không Ok
tôi kể hồi cấp 2 ở thôi Yêu Đơn Phương
bạn đấy Sau đó thì ở đương nhiên là
không thành bạn ơi cho tôi là fan tô nữa
bạn tốt sau đó thì ở
cho
tôi kiểu
ngồi ngay cạnh bạn đấy rồi mình đúng
kiểu dạng là học hộ bạn đấy luôn đấy
ạ Bạn ấy thì kiểu dạng hả
ấn tượng đến lớp để cho mình làm kiểu
kiểu đúng nghĩa là gì hết nước ngủ rồi
ăn chơi cái hư rồi mình xong rồi thì làm
hai bài luôn sợ cho cả tôi và cả bọn đấy
mà Huế tôi xếp thứ ba lớp còn ấy sẽ thứ
Bảy lớp đấy
Ừ ông kiến trúc sư vẫn phải thi vẽ
ở lễ hội đại học ở thì về không biết bây
giờ đến hồi tôi phải thi vẽ đấy mà tôi
không giỏi vẽ tôi giỏi vẽ công nghệ thôi
thì công nghệ thì được em còn nữa vẽ về
thì bình thường thì không
sim mà
nhưng mà đại khái Thì hồi đấy đã từng
nói lỡ mỏ một câu hỏi ước mơ của mình đó
là vì sao tao muốn làm cái trúc sư Nghị
định nói là kiểu Ta muốn kiếm tao muốn
thiết kế cái phòng phòng ngủ tao như
phòng bầu dục để phòng vô dục và ở của
nhà trắng đấy
để làm phòng với ta nó khó lắm nhìn thấy
rồi Nghe có phải dậy rồi Thôi cái thì
cái phòng như khó này thôi tôi nói nhầm
sang nữa
có giống lầu xanh Lầu Năm Góc ở nhầm sữa
đậu xanh
sôi vợ lấy que kiểu gì
đoạn này có ghi âm nghỉ thôi coi như
không có gì nữa bây giờ kênh nha
các bạn lớn nó ở nhà các bạn không cần
phải hiểu tôi vừa nói gì à
à à
ông thầy dạy bao lần rồi đó
em mãi mãi máu rồi à
từ hồi bé tôi đã tôi đã chạy gái thôi
ngay từ hồi mẫu giáo ý
khác rồi bây giờ thì người yêu à
cái từ Trại cảm thấy anh nhá Cẩn thận
kênh là bị bay rồi kêu là bị đánh tiền
báo mà
thôi vẫn bị lạc hơi chủ đề quá chút là
tôi từng nói về cái vụ thì ứng xử như
thế tiếp theo còn nghề gì nhỉ ngày dễ
học cũng một cái hay nhưng mà tại sao
tôi lại thích ngành dạy học bởi vì à
Ừ tôi tưởng là dậy dạy cho chính kèm cho
các bạn đồng lứa và thấy cũng ổn bà thậm
chí là lần cuối Tôi từng kèm trước khi
mà định theo về nghề sư phạm này đó là
tôi kèm cho một đứa một đứa mà ngày hôm
sau nó sẽ thi môn à
ở môn kiểu mua Na triệu muốn chết
Ừ thì nó đầu tiên rồi nhỏ nhắn tin nhiều
tôi kiểm tra miệng hội nó kiểu kiểm tra
học thuộc lòng học vẹt đấy đấy bởi vì
hôm sau đó thi trắc nghiệm rồi bà kia
kiểm tra của ABCD vãi chưởng học chua
đấy
Ở đây có đề cương hết mà sợ thì tôi bảo
cái này sẽ mà tôi gì học em hiểu ngay
để sôi nó quay ra hỏi tôi là tiền tao
thấy có người bảo là một chiếc rễ đấy à
Xong rồi tôi giảng lại cho nó hai tiếng
đồng hồ rồi nó bạn ơi kiu cho ngày hôm
sau nó thi được 8 về để khoe xong rồi nó
Anh bảo kiểu Ông dạy dễ hiểu ta hướng
thì lúc ấy tôi mới càng khẳng định thêm
để việc à Cái cách việc cả tôi dậy
Ừ tôi không hẳn là tôi vẫn không tự tin
là tôi dậy rất nổi Ôi không Tôi chưa qua
cái sự đào tạo Sư phạm nào cả nên tôi tự
tin ở điểm một cái đó là khi mà tôi hiểu
cái gì rồi rồi tôi nói lại thì theo
phong cách kiểu dạng là cố đơn giản hóa
nó đi Tôi nghĩ mọi thứ cho nó đơn giản
đi ngân hàng ra là tôi có thể nói được
cho người khác kia
anh kể cái sự đơn giản nó ví dụ về sự
Cái Chết tôi dậy bạn ấy những cái từ đó
tạo độ lớn giống như là kiểu à
bộ công cụ lại công cụ sản xuất chẳng
hạn cái bản chất Nó là cái gì gần gì đó
chiết Ờ thử cao nó nó cứ từ đao to búa
lớn đúng không thì tôi sẽ dậy thôi sẽ cố
hiểu
kiểu sẽ nói kiểu đơn giản
ở ngôi nhà bây giờ tôi bây giờ mới Ông
hỏi lại tôi về chiếc thì được ra cũng
không ngờ làm đâu ngờ bây giờ gặp đại
học thì tôi sẽ nhớ cả môn lận luật luật
cũng thế tương đối đáp trả luật đã chết
rồi thầy cô mà ở trên
hồi học đại học
xe điện núi cao ấy điện với 9 phẩy cơ Để
tôi tự tin rồi khoản luật với Triết về
cơ bản nó dễ mà tôi thấy là nó làm suốt
đời sống thực tế
Ừ đúng rồi đấy cái bạn kia nói chuẩn đó
là nhiều giáo viên thì cứ kiểu muốn muốn
học sinh cảm thấy ở môn này là một môn
rất là cần phải nghiêm túc học Hải Vân
cố làm phức tạp hóa lên đấy Kiểu vừa kìa
áo kiểu dạng là giống như kiểu sợ sinh
viên thấy em Môn này dễ quá ý thì sẽ
khinh thường mua lấy sao ấy hiểu Cố làm
phức tạp hóa vấn đề lên sâu phải làm mới
sinh viên sợ muốn này Vân sợ nhà giáo
Việt không hiểu để làm gì rõ ràng ở thì
tôi đang hướng đến cái mục tiêu ngược
lại mấy ông khéo ạ Tới đâu cố gì cho bé
uống cảm thấy à thân thiện nhất có thể
mua này có phải dễ tiếp cận nước vỡ hệ
của bọn đấy rất nhiều giáo viên thì nó
kiểu tôi không hiểu lắm để đi dạy cốt là
để mà hình như là để mà khiến cho họ Nể
mình hay sợ mình hơn đấy đấy cả thế
khiến trong bô này khó hơn này ai là cậu
muốn đấy phải rắc rối hơn này đấy Lằng
nhằng hơn này
ô chữ đó không phải khiến cho mình cảm
thấy gần gũi tự nhiên nữa mình cảm thấy
học môn đấy Ở học xong mình chả làm được
cái gì rồi thứ nhất thứ hai là kiểu mình
bị mông lung ấy đúng không
ở nhà bây giờ tôi đi học ở trên đó
trường cũng có vài thầy cô cũng như thế
mà nhưng mà tôi tôi Tao bảo rồi tôi từng
đọc sách
cho tôi không ngại đọc sách Thế là tôi
đọc qua thì tôi thấy nó hay thật thì
thôi Tìm hiểu các thứ thứ
anh và tôi không thấy ở môn nào muốn
thừa gà tôi đều tôi có quan điểm suy
nghĩ như thế thành ra hơi học học nó
không thừa mà đúng không
Ừ nhưng mà còn để nói giáo viên thì chỗ
gặp rất nhiều thành phần
mình may mà cũng có giáo viên tốt cho
từng gặp hệ tôi trân trọng những giáo
viên như thế
Ừ chứ không phải nói là từ trước đến nay
tôi toàn gặp và viên tốt không tôi không
được may mắn như thế gặp rất nhiều thể
thành phần rất nhiều giáo viên rất nhiều
giáo viên đã từng vùi dập tôi cũng gõ
Ừ nhưng mà cái đấy Đấy cũng là lý do mà
tại sao tôi chọn dạy học bởi vì A cái
riêng phải cái ngành này tôi thấy ở giáo
viên chung của ngành Công nghệ thông tin
này
và đặc biệt là giáo viên đại học thì ở
đang hơi bị bận bận hiểu dại dại khá
nhiều nên là Và họ cũng có tuổi họ phải
học lên thạc sĩ thậm chí Tiến sĩ vảy gà
họ bị lý thuyết quá nhiều họ cũng do quá
bận thôi thì chả có gia đình nữa vật họ
tuổi rồi này ra là họ
ý kiến thức của họ lý thuyết quá nhiều
thậm chí là kiến thức Còn cũ đấy nên
thành ra là phim mà họ dậy nó bị rất
nhiều vấn đề kết hợp việc họ thì nó đi
nó lại một thứ gì đó vài năm rồi nghe họ
sau khi mà ông nói đi nói lại một câu
câu đủ ấy là một câu chuyện ông sẽ cắt
bớt đi ăn bớt rồi đi khỏi ông thêm thắt
cái gì ở linh tinh mà ông sẽ không nói
được trọn vẹn một câu chuyện sau mười là
năm nói đúng không chán thế tao thầy cô
dạy lâu quá rồi thành ra hiểu Khi mà dậy
lại cứ thứ sẽ bị thiếu sót cái gì đó đấy
cho nên thành ra là tôi nghĩ là
tôi hơn các thầy cô hiện tại ở ở cái
khoản đấy tôi vẫn còn mới còn trẻ có
nhiều thuyết có thể cập nhật được thêm
rất nhiều thú và đặc biệt là thực hành
tôi vẻ nhiều hơn các thầy cô vẫn có thầy
cô dồi kiến thức cực bị lỗi thôi và Vần
rồi và cái thứ hai nữa làm được ở thầy
cô bây giờ vẫn còn đang
Anh đang nhờ khúc hát tâm lý với sinh
viên đó lắm
ở đây nên thành ra là cậu nhiều không
phải thầy cô nào cũng trở dạng là thực
hành được này hay là truyền cảm hứng của
cho sinh viên
Ừ cái mục đích của các bạn đi học Thực
ra là không phải học kiến thức đâu các
bạn vẫn thể tự học kiến thức tôi từng
nói rồi gỡ từng nói là tôi kèm cho một
bạn bạn đầu tiên tôi kèm lập trình kèm
đúng với hai ba buổi để lập trình và tôi
dậy hẳn cái nâng cao cứ phải dạy cái các
bạn có dậy với cách mấy ông rồi Lúc đầu
đứa học ghi chỉ nghe vẻ hay đấy nếu lỡ
thì một cái khó cái thứ hai đứa dậy ở về
ra Switch sau đó thì bạn ấy tự học sau
đó hơn một năm thôi nói chuyện lại thì
bạn rồi Đã làm được với phần mềm sự nói
chung là làm tự mò làm tiện ích các tiện
ích của trình duyệt thì bằng gia súc
tích mà các thứ thứ là ra hết rồi Mà em
học ở nốt TF rồi
Ừ thì đó là tôi truyền cảm hứng cho bạn
đấy thôi còn kiến thức tôi không thể
chuyển hết rồi cho bạn đấy tất cả những
thứ đấy phải tự học mà nhưng mình truyền
được cảm hứng và mình có cái tâm thì
thôi nghĩa Đó là một cái lớn rồi ông ạ
khỏe thôi đỡ hơn mấy hôm trước rồi Nhưng
mà chắc chắn là không thể nói là khỏi
ngay được rồi
thế nhưng có vẻ hôm nay
mày tâm sự được
từ hôm nay thì cứ chữabài nốt cho các
bạn nó có gì thì tôi tâm sự Cái này hay
cực tí ông sẽ biết được Tại sao tôi để
hẳn có cái chữ này đây Cái gì đấy phố
sự phổ nhạc cũ của tôi
hai nhóm nhóm có đây chưa nhỉ
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
ô ô ai để lỗ ca mà mày Thế mình không
Mình đang mặc quần áo
Ừ ừ tắt hả
mấy ngày nay có được tắm đâu
anh
nói chung là đầu tóc bết đó tôi vừa rồi
nó bảo tôi phải tôi phải tắm khô thôi
lau qua người không có gội đầu gì à
Ừ thế bạn nữ rồi tôi dại gái mà
anh vẫn cứ bảo là bạn đấy yêu cầu thôi
mở cam một buổi livestream ở đó từ hôm
nào tôi sẽ nói chung là thực ra tôi
không ngại vụ đấy
Ừ tôi chỉ sợ mấy ông ngồi nhìn tôi chả
có cái nợ thì chỉ cần Tâm và đặc biệt là
ngựa đâu đằng sau thôi về sau xuất hiện
một cái gì đó mà tôi không làm chủ được
thì nó không hay cho lắm này tôi nghĩ à
Tôi nói chung là dạy học hạn chế việc mà
họ không liên quan đến cái học sẽ bỏ qua
đến cái kênh của tôi sẽ có hiểu gì về
sao chẳng có nộm mặt tôi thì có phải đã
tôi từ trước hai ẩn danh đâu trên
Facebook phải có mà Thì họ trên chính
kênh này cũng có vài video cũ đầu tiên
của tôi còn quay Tôi thuyết trình cài
khóa học nào đó cơ mà thuyết trình tiếng
Anh là chương trình Ai đấy
Ừ thì à
anh về sau tôi đang hưởng đến có bạn
cũng gợi ý về sao tôi có thể đi những
cái buổi ví dụ À bởi sắp tới offline này
chắc là tôi sẽ quay lại video rồi tôi
cắt chỉnh sửa gì đó để làm cái video của
tôi bảo là cứ cái này sẽ hướng là Block
mà thành ra cái sáu sẽ có chia sẻ với gì
đó Cái gì hay thì tôi sẽ quay quay lại
hai hoặc cả tôi sẽ nói tâm sự mới gì đó
có thể không quay mặt mình nhưng mà thể
quay xung quanh các thử thứ Ừ lúc đấy
tôi sẽ kiếm camera trị nữa nhé
Ô cái con điện thoại của tôi đang không
hạt là chị lắm nó
xiaomi.max ít nhưng mà hai năm trước rồi
nó không chịu lắm được tôi về sau tôi sẽ
cố
anh nói chung là tôi sẽ xây dựng phát
triển cái kênh mình nó hơi bị sĩ một tí
không
chú ý ông là học cái A
Nghe cải lương cao nào ạ
tôi mới đi ỉa
kênh này tự nhiên bây giờ lên đến 10.000
người theo dõi sợ không hiểu mấy ông
theo dõi nhiều làm gì à
dõi ra treo để đấy thôi chứ lượng người
xem thì không thể nỗi thế thể hiểu theo
dõi ủng hộ rồi là tội có kêu gọi mấy ông
theo dõi hãy like hay bình luận vào giờ
đâu đúng không ạ Không
không muốn mình làm người nổi tiếng lắm
nếu tôi có để ý tôi có thể chứ Đấy Nếu
mà giả sử đột nhiên tự nhiên mình bị
giảm thì chúng tỏ mình có vấn đề không ạ
mày tăng lên thì thì thì có vẻ là tốt
đấy tôi tôi chỉ quan điểm để tôi cho tôi
không ăn điểm được
mong nhiều nhiều quá sợ lắm
khi bé cư nổi tiếng hơn một tí phải cẩn
thận ăn nói mệt
em có nhậu hôm nay vào thuyết trình cho
đi nghỉ không thuyết trình là tôi ngồi
tâm sự cả buổi đấy ở nhóm vào Có vài
nhóm cần vào chữ mà hôm nay buổi trưa
nốt nào
muộn đâu bởi vì bây giờ có rất nhiều bạn
học họ bắt đầu khóa cơ bản mới bắt đầu
biết đến kênh của mình học khóa cơ bản
mà bạn cứ học thôi đương nhiên là bây
giờ sẽ nhiều điểm bây giờ nếu các bạn
bắt đầu học hoặc cả chỉ học chậm một vài
buồn cho các bạn khác thì đương nhiên nó
sẽ không nghe trực tiếp được Kiểu này
thì mới hiểu được
cũng hơi bị thiệt thòi các bạn vì về sau
mình cũng không chắc là về sau mình sẽ
dạy lại mấy cái này mà có những video
rồi thì chả các bạn cũng học những vị từ
những video đấy thôi
Ừ đúng rồi định hướng đến mình chuyên ở
mình chuyên bác em
Tự nhiên bây giờ mình làm ở công ty Full
stack và cả ra Switch nhưng mà ở
gọi là Uyên người Spears bị xử lý Speed
thì cũng được nhé còn lấy ở để xuyên với
cả fernand theo kiểu lại làm xé thì thôi
tôi ngồi hai tiếng rồi ngồi sửa cái CS
mệt lắm không sửa xe đâu chịu
À xin bảo vệ đồ án 1A
hai nhóm nhóm nào mà vẫn còn đau làm đón
một đấy muốn bảo vệ thì chắc là sẽ inbox
mình bảo vệ riêng luôn sợ không có
livestream kiểu ngay nữa này
có pin của nhóm vào để mà làm nốt mà
là một tí có rất nhiều cái Pocket mới
gần đây rồi cho xe mới nhất không biết
có thêm gì mới không
Ừ anh Pocket này có phải cả Pocket ở đây
nó có cái á
Ừ nó hỗ trợ cả view nó với ông đọc qua
đấy ví dụ có cả không còn eta2 liên quan
gì đó tôi có đọc ở đây Hồi đấy có cái á
So sánh đôi sex
có la liga với view này
Ừ đấy like nghe có một Blade này là gì
gió không review này rất nhiều bất cứ ở
đây nó hỗ trợ
ờ ờ
tế thực tế nhá Thì bây giờ người ta dùng
led làm bác em sau đó thì ở file thì
tách hẳn ra để làm view hoặc nắp giống
như ở công ty tôi
còn nếu mà thực tế hơn nữa thì gà TP là
vẫn chưa đủ nhanh bằng nhiều ngôn ngữ
khác này nên là
pp nó sẽ chửi chỉ xử lý ở vài cái tác vụ
đơn giản Còn những cái tác vụ gì đó cần
ví dụ điển hình liên quan vòng lại Ạ
vòng lặp tầm chục nghìn thì
xử lý hùng anh nên qua đến hàng có số
lớn hơn rồi các ngôn ngữ khác mà sẽ
nhanh hơn rửa bạn thì có lời đẩy sang
ngôn ngữ khác làm ngôn ngữ kho để xử lý
những cái gì đỏ nhanh cần phải tốc độ
ngay sau đó thì
sau đó thì có thể trả lời về PB in ra
thôi cũng được nhiều cách
Ừ
cái này thì nếu mà bạn họ như thế thì
chả Bạn đang làm cái dự án thì quy mô
nhỏ Thực ra đây là mỗi level thôi ở đủ
có thể là học thêm file view nữa cho
biết kết hợp cả hai cũng được Còn khi mà
vào công ty đương nhiên là tùy theo công
ty nữa mà đúng không Thì lúc này các bạn
sẽ biết được là nên phải làm gì
Ừ đúng rồi anh Tuấn thì bây giờ anh ấy
vào với bạn gái anh ở trong Nam rồi
thì sẽ tách hẳn ra tay thảm ra một thư
mục riêng đấy để mà pp à
oils sẽ là bác Em thuộc dạng là một cái
server api để cho thằng thằng à file nó
sẽ gọi đến cái Rossi đấy
Ừ cái này thì à
đề cao bản chất mình vào công ty này thì
công ty làm sẵn cấu hình các thứ thứ rồi
Mình cũng chưa cấu hình qua rồi Mình gần
đây bị đang định làm cái trang web vệ
sinh mình sẽ làm như thế Tôi chưa cấu
hình ảnh độ trường pin dậy mấy ông hưởng
như thế nào
Ừ Ok Nếu hôm nay buồn tâm sự hiện tại sẽ
tranh thủ trả lời câu hỏi đây đã
anh tran thi công làm gái xinh không
khai nha
Ừ cái này cùng Khanh hôm khác hôm khác
cái
tôi từng nói rồi Làm cái gì ai vậy đó
của mình à
The Best Music
thôi trách này đi Ờ
kiểm thì ông Lê Na
theo cái sở thích của mấy ông không hẳn
là sở thích mà kiểu dạng là ông thích
làm thế ông thích làm là một cái riêng
gì gì đó cho cá nhân ông để ngoài việc
là để cải thiện kĩ năng của ông sẽ cảm
thấy cái ngành lập trình này nó bị nó có
rất nhiều về hai chứ nó không bị nhàm
chán chứ giờ tôi giao đâu bán trong mấy
ông rồi Ông mấy ông chỉ cứ làm mấy cái
đấy nó sẽ hơi bị khô khan mày không hiểu
không tự làm một cái gì đó sản phẩm của
riêng mình nó chỉ cần nhỏ hơn được tiền
thì ngồi trước tôi bảo ở chỗ làm chatbot
làm vệ sinh này trang web chia sẻ với
Vân rất nhiều cái họ tôi làm tool
Facebook để tôi chia sẻ cho cộng đồng
rồi cộng đồng mà Cảm ơn tôi Tôi cảm thấy
kiểu mình làm gì có ích rồi mình thì vui
rồi thì ông sẽ thấy đam mê ngày ngày hơn
và từ đó thì ông sẽ phát triển thêm kỹ
năng Minh không ạ Nên cải pazec rất là
quan trọng mấy về việc làm đồ án mà tôi
hay vào kiểu đang thúc mấy ông đã chuẩn
bị ông nên khó những kẻ ghét tôi trách
của riêng mình testojack cả những cái dự
án rất nhỏ không cần phải to quá nên là
nhỏ và nên là bút mình để cho ông tự cải
thiện kỹ năng của ông đều ngoại tại mấy
ông cứ tự nghĩ best forex cho riêng mình
đi
Ừ cái này là hôm trước có một bạn khuyên
mình là khi mà dậy thì mình nên vẽ sơ đồ
cái sơ đồ một cái sơ đồ giống kiểu sơ đồ
tư duy hay ạ một là thế hay ở cái sơ đồ
thì đỏ sâu đầu thuật toán là bắt đầu là
gì sôi xử lý do gì cho quay lại như thế
nào các thứ thứ trồng cây phân tích Chức
năng ạ thì kể cái này cái cái đấy thì
chả để và để tổng kết lại buổi hôm đấy
làm những cái gì
xe chở để về sau khi mà dậy một cái gì ở
xong tôi sẽ vẽ lại theo sơ đồ thuật toán
để cho các bạn hiểu được cả bộ không đấy
học như học
nên hiểu là như thế nào cái luồng tư duy
xử lý là như thế nào để bé ông hình dung
hơn
tôi sẽ để lại đây cho tôi nhớ
a tiếp theo là mẹo vặt tôi à
em có tên là nhiều Cái này mấy ông biết
rồi Hòa Tôi từng nói rồi nhưng tôi xin
phép nó lại một lần nữa đó là thứ nhất
là cách tìm kiếm nhanh cái này tôi từng
chia sẻ khi nhóm rồi cách cái tìm kiếm
ngay đây tao có tận 2 cách để tìm kiếm
nhanh nhưng ở cái đầu tiên tôi tìm kiếm
nhé Bây giờ sửa tôi vẫn thấy là nhiều
nhiều ông máu ngoài nghề ông đó thật là
nhiều bạn nữ sao là cái bạn lại không
biết công nghệ không nói ví dụ là xử lý
ai cái ông vẫn còn lên Google dùng
Chrome dùng chữa rôm nhưng vẫn lên
Google chấm con như thế này chịu gõ PC
cửa để tìm kiếm đấy thay vì rõ ràng là
mình ông hoàn toàn là có thể là khó
thẳng lên hãy địa chỉ như thế này là
được tìm kiếm được rồi đúng không ạ Đấy
ờ
Ừ nhưng mà ở đây là tìm kiếm mặc định
của Google Chrome
Thế còn tìm kiếm những cái khác thì sao
em chẳng có ai cả tháng zoom thằng Mít
và cảnh báo tôi tôi độc thoại một mình
chưa này Đậu Sạch thế tìm kiếm cái khác
thì sao giả sử là thường là rất nhiều
trang web này có rất nhiều cái tìm kiếm
điển hình nhé địa hình giống như là à
em xử như này đi
từ tiếng Anh từ từ tiếng Việt đúng không
hay kiểu này Hello chị ạ
hình ảnh như này
đi tìm bé Ông thấy Đây là tìm kiếm không
ạ Tại sao phải tìm kiếm rõ ràng mình
nhập cái gì đó rồi ấn enter cho nó sẽ để
đẩy lên hai địa chỉ tìm kiếm cái gì đó
đúng ạ thì mấy ông nhỉ kỹ trên anh địa
chỉ nhé Nó có chữ Hello Đúng cái thứ mà
tôi nhập đây đúng không Tại tao sẽ copy
đường link này sẽ ấn vào đây Cài đặt sau
đó tôi sẽ có sốt đó tìm kiếm sát ở đây
để trong Sài Gòn không để tiếng Anh nhé
Tôi đang đến 1 tỷ nhưng anh lại ông sẽ
ấn vào cái dưới cái cái cái sắt engine
này rồi Cái này và bạn này thì ông có
thể tạo thêm ở đây tôi đã tạo trước cũng
phải cái rồi có rất nhiều cái ở đây là
mặc định của thằng cụ Chrome nó đọc được
nhờ có nhiều cái còn ông muốn tạo thêm ở
đây ví dụ giả sử như tôi ở đây tạo cái
dịch này ạ Tôi thử Xóa này đi coi như
chưa có đi
anh phải đi nhá
Ê hồi trưa tôi tạo lắm cực Nếu không thể
không
Nghe ca nhạc
chữ à đầu tiên là cái này là từ điện đi
từ điển anh-việt tên như này tiếp theo
chúng tôi gọi chữ dịch này là tôi viết
tắt sau đỏ đi rồi thay thế cái chữ Hello
này là Phần trăm S
lưu lại này bây giờ mỗi lần tôi mở tab
mới tôi gọi chiến dịch cách a một cái ví
dụ ABC ngay khi nó sẽ tìm kiếm trang này
theo dạng ABC nhà nó dịch không ạ Éo
hiểu gì ông ạ da xịn
chứ không phải dùng dấu cách thì có thể
dùng giáo tát được nghỉ ngày thứ hai nữa
chắc ạ đó
em đi chợ
có phải là cách tìm kiếm cái này rất phù
hợp giúp nhưng mà ông vừa thấy ngoài tìm
kiếm chỗ dịch ra có thể tìm kiếm spectre
lau nhà chẳng hạn của este xong rồi alo
equus chẳng hạn đấy nó sẽ tìm kiếm hộ
cho mình nộp cầu FeO
Ở
nhà chẳng hạn
mày Ông thấy tôi còn tìm kiếm trong nhóm
mà như tìm công ty chả thế
Ê hồi đấy à chưa tin công ty đang rất
nhiều phải liệu và tôi thường phải tìm
kiếm rất nhiều tài liệu đã ví dụ Giả sử
đây
a a b c nha
Ê mày ông phải đường lên nó dạng này
không đấy thì tôi sẽ sửa lại đường Linh
ở đây là sự Xóa đi làm lại này gọi chữ j
Chu này xong rồi à
Anh nhầm đây có gì hay vậy
- Chu sẽ từ viết tắt này hai cái nay lắm
phần trăm m điều lại di tru cách này Đấy
nghĩa tìm trong di truyền không ạ xong
rồi JAV ở lại ừ ừ
ở đó thì có anh Tráng 15 cái vụ này
Ừ cái à
dùng được nhé Chẳng thế
tôi giới thiệu Thế thôi nhá mày không
được áp dụng gì
ờ ờ tiếp theo là thậm chí là có thể tìm
kiếm ha
đi tìm kiếm theo người ví dụ là giả sử
là
khi tìm kiếm người nào đó ở đây chẳng ạ
bí ẩn Pipo này
gì đấy
cho tôi thường Ai tìm kiếm nhiều người
khá là nhiều rồi kìa trong web gái xinh
mà nên là nha cầu và ai đó bình luận tên
bạn nào đó tôi sẽ tranh thủ Tìm kiếm bạn
đấy
cho nên là một ở tôi sẽ làm thì cậu
giống như tôi vừa làm cái thứ hai đó là
tôi mấy ông thấy ở đây có mấy cái búp
mát của tôi bước mát Ở đây còn trứng gà
để tôi gõ tìm kiếm một ai đó giờ sửa
Long nha Để ạ Vâng tôi rồi nó cũng sẽ nó
sẽ lấy đúng cái thứ thuốc nhật để truyền
hình Thành địa chỉ như thế này Thế làm
thế nào để làm được cái bút mát 9 ngày
thì tôi sẽ edit trong mấy ông xem nhé
về bản chất nó sẽ là
cài đặt là gì
về
bản chất nó là như thế này đây cái cái
này nó là ra Suite và ông phải khai báo
nó ra Switch thì mới được
À mà em mới hiểu là kiểu ngôn ngữ về mà
chạy rồi ông sẽ báo hàm nhiều như này
khai báo hàm kiểu như này là sao khai
báo Hàn kiểu như này là ông sẽ chạy được
cái hàng này luôn đấy Kiểu kiểu như này
và bản chất cái Hà mày thì nó là nó sẽ
bao gồm nhất là cái hiển thị lên cái
phom để cho ông nhập vào này sau đó thì
nếu mà giả sử tôi
anh một lát Tôi bắt buộc cả tôi phải
không Tôi phải điền và phải không được
chồng ấy thì sẽ lập tức là window Open
tức là mở ra tab mới mà tao mời cái gì
mà tao mời cái cái tên tôi chuyển bảo
thôi còn like này thì các bạn biết rồi
anh này chỉ đơn giản là nó làm ở ta mới
thôi
Em hãy chỉ ngắn gọn một cái loại sẽ đơn
giản như thế là tôi có thể Cậu ấn vào
đấy gõ Tìm kiếm ai đó thậm chí á tiện
hơn là sửa thôi của Linh Vậy à Linh
istar mà đấy Chẳng hạn sẽ gõ vào là sử
ngay là chuno Tokyo trở lại
cô gái sẽ nhảy ra Instagram của Yoyo
anh nghe đang ảnh gái à cái đậu xanh
từng chỉ mấy ông ngồi tí cái cover dung
thì chị vào để soi ngoài việc là Soi ảnh
Phóng to ra ấn nút s sẽ lưu ảnh này
Ê bà ấn nút t để mở ra ảnh ta mới này
ở nhà thôi tôi nói thế thôi Tớ không tải
ảnh về đâu
Ừ có gì em nhỉ
Ừ cái đấy à Swift này Suite Mày thử cà
ông thể làm rất nhiều cái không phải mỗi
cái như tôi vào tôi có thể là dụng tự
động hơn đầy tôi chia sẻ Switch khá
nhiều đấy tôi chia sẻ Swift Ừ cái việc
là kiểu autoscroll này tôi kẹo kéo muốn
kéo xuống kiểu tầm tự động kéo hộ mình
ấy sẽ hiểu ngay
cuối trong vòng 10 giây thôi Thì như thế
anh như này I tell you
Ở đây có nhiều cái đây nữa thì mình cũng
sẽ tự hiểu
Có ai bỏ đi mà không cần nữa
và cuối cùng là phím tắt
anh phím tắt của tôi thì can thì mày ông
thầy đó Khi mà tôi chia sẻ cái bàn phím
để tôi làm phím tắt thì tôi sẽ sử dụng
phím tắt khá nhiều tôi ít khi bật con
chuột lắm Nếu mấy ông để kỹ giúp đỡ tôi
ăn control-t để 8 mới ăn cho nắp lưu
đóng bác con sunsister để khôi phục khỏi
top đã vừa đón đúng không ạ ấy
có thêm những cái nữa giống như được
chụp phải đây để mà đọc để mút tiếng này
ghim để xóa
em tắt những cái Tab toàn bộ áp khác lại
Vân ra mấy ông phải mò cái này nhiều
run vừa rồi à Nếu ông cha cái ra mà ừ
Em Hát Còn gì nữa nhỉ
Em hãy mở control để mà nhảy lên cái này
nhanh này không biết mày ông có đi không
đấy một vào thế hệ F3 được
có sao đâu ngày bà bước 13 là để tìm
kiếm nhanh không Nói rồi control-f cũng
để tìm kiếm nhanh
sẽ phải mẹ của tôi ăn chuông si.pnj
không nói gì nhé Xin ờ cho mày biết rồi
trình rồi có phải cái bên lập trình thì
tôi không chia sẻ hôm nay
đoạn Speed của tôi đấy
ở bài này sweepers Chỉ đơn giản là cứ
Kéo xuống kéo xuống mà nó như thế này
chị sẽ là đầu tiên à Lấy cái body body ở
ngoài
ý là tôi chia sẻ trên liên kết H của tôi
một lần nữa thì phải
Cho xem Đại Phát
được 2000 đây này nó hơi thấp
thì mình lấy hết mình cần lấy chiều dài
thì mình lấy chiều dài của cả cái của
cải cái 2000 thì gọi đến một quả thôi
Còn cái này toàn bộ chiều dài của tranh
hiện tại dù người đến cuối tra cái này
tốt hơn này sửa đây đã
ăn xong cho sữa này à
chưa hiểu này nó
a when I'm ok
Thôi cho mày không dễ nhìn hơn tí nhé
body này soi lấy á chiều dài của tất cả
những cá thu này nhập số dây mượn quyển
này ở dạng cuộn thôi ta mau là kiểu Khi
nào Nương ấy à không nó cứ chạy chạy
chạy liên tục
khi ổn thôi mẹ như thế đó
cô gái kể lại không hẳn xịn lắm gọi tạm
được dùng được
ở đây cái tiện ích đấy là
a small totop tiện ích này cũng xịn
em không thấy à Nó sẽ hiển thị lên cái
đây này để bấm lên trên nó cầm Suối Hai
tiện này
để ý ra còn có nhiều cái thư mục ngon
danh sách cái đen tối hơn mục ảnh cái
này chuyển ra là những cái ảnh cái gì à
những ảnh mà tôi chưa tải thôi lưu lại
rồi đấy
xe tải tôi sẽ phải tải hết cho đúng ai
Ừ ừ đúng rồi chủ yếu trong này ảnh nhà
cô gái trung nữa tôi không có tài khoản
chung mẹ tôi không hiểu rõ được tôi lưu
tạm là các bạn nữ ở trong đấy hiểu để
phía sau tôi có tài khoản chung rồi tôi
sẽ tải hết toàn bộ ảnh ở đây về
mình có dậy đi dai bà Tần không và có
bạn hiện tại cũng đang hỏi là cốt theo
quy tắc nào không ạ
Ừ thứ nhất là thử ca là mình không
chuyên về hướng đối tượng lắm Mình không
hẳn là học chuyên về java để mà biết về
kiến thức với số ít là kiểu nói chung
nhà cấu trúc chuẩn các thử thứ thì mình
hiện tại thì như mình chỉ các bạn là
mình mới chị theo cái phong cách là của
Lazio best practice là này là theo kiểu
phong cách gọi là kiểu nên đặt tên như
nào rồi nên để file như nào các thứ cho
hợp lý tôi vẫn theo quy tắc ở trên này
ngoài ra thì không ạ
ờ ờ kiểu dáng nào không
Ừ không hẳn là biết chuẩn mấy cái kia
lắm nên là nên là thơ ca là cũng không
biết truyền đạt nó mới ông kiểu như thế
nào hơi khó
Ừ nhưng mà tôi sẽ tìm hiểu dần dần cái
đấy cái đấy rồi Các mình có thể cùng cố
thêm được sau không không quan trọng lắm
và đặc biệt à Đi làm ở công ty thì các
bạn sẽ học được từ những người trước
Kiểu gì người chưa chẳng cốt rồi thì các
bạn sẽ học hỏi từ những người trước thôi
các bạn không phải cần phải lo nghĩ quá
nhiều về cái đấy
cái Phúc à
chú trọng Dead rồi đấy
này nếu mày ông cậu Chuyên dealer có thứ
bài hát Tôi vừa thấy các bạn SV gì vậy
có gì nhỉ
không chữ bài tôi tâm sự nó tắt máy ngủ
đấy
anh alo
Ừ không thì hôm nay mày ông tâm sự gì
được không còn chữa gì Hỏi gì tâm sự gì
cũng được
dậy ở Bởi vì
đó cũng không Mình bận lắm mới dậy tôi
thì có suy nghĩ đó là chúng ta đôi khi ở
em có những ngày đủ tỉnh táo gì cả Có
những ngày tỉnh táo vàng ngày thì những
ngày thì tỉnh táo Dọn cả ngày tôi sẽ
ngồi làm việc hoặc cả đi bất thường ở
nên đi bốc mấy ông sẽ thử ở đây tôi nói
nếu không nên
có cốt khí Ami ông là thông minh quá bởi
vì ông sẽ được trả lại thông minh hơn để
mà ông đi Bắc Thế bạn đấy
Nên là những cái lốc ống thông minh thì
lúc này ông nên sửa Bắc Còn Nghĩa lúc
con tỉnh táo ấy thì không nên sửa bắt đi
tiêu hóa kiểm tra lại những cốt với từng
cốt xem có vấn đề gì không vân vân đấy
con à
à Còn những ngày mà ông gọi là ông Bình
thường thôi thì lúc này ông mình có nên
ngồi cốt mới tạo ra bất không ạ
Anh hiểu hiểu vừa nêu cái công việc này
là công việc
cách tạo là mất cái
đi gỡ bất đồng ngoạn nên là ông phải cân
bằng hai cái yêu tôi đấy
có thời gian để mà sửa bức đó tốn hơn
nhiều thời gian tạo ở bước cốt một đoạn
thì nhắn thôi Nhưng mà sửa loạn đấy mới
mất nhiều ra nó không ạ Đây đây là ông
khi ông tỉnh táo đi Tôi nghĩ ông nên
à à Nên cậu ngồi giải quyết những cái
cái cũ và xem kỹ lại những cái cũ xem
gần đây gì không ở Vân
em còn những lúc mà thật sự ở những cái
lúc mà ông chán nản ông chẳng muốn làm
gì
Ừ thì ông có nên làm gì cả bởi không
Không nên ngồi cốt lúc đấy một câu lúc
này nhá Mà chị tạo nhiều rắc rối hơn về
sau phải giải quyết thôi
Ừ mai và thử ta tôi bảo rồi tôi vẫn thấy
mai khi mà thôi vào công ty thoải mái
cho thử thứ đưa người đưa như vẫn không
đủ hấp dẫn như nhiều công ty cho nó có
một sự thoải mái cho phù hợp với tôi
hiện tại kiểu à
làm rất là nhiều có hôm thì mình không
không thể là mình không muốn làm không
muốn làm đây không phải là không thích
làm chị nó già vì mình mệt mỏi đấy chẳng
hạn thế Thì cái dù dạy sử việc tôi ốm
như này chẳng hạn
thì vẫn có thể nhỉ nó không ảnh hưởng gì
cả
Java thì có sao không Không sao vẫn lập
trình không ảnh hưởng gì cả
Ừ nhưng mà ông làm và nếu mà tôi dậy
không thấy p mà ông Ông bắt tôi chấm đồ
án zava thì tôi sẽ không chấm của ông
đâu
tâm sự về cái chú ý nghĩa con phố của
tôi ngủ chưa nhé còn chưa Tôi bị giải
kiểu nửa đêm tự như ngồi nghĩ Tại sao
nói chung mà ngồi nghĩ tên các địa danh
ở Hà Nội tôi đi ngồi tra Google kể tên
các địa danh
ông kia hỏi vợ tôi trả lời nó cả này nhé
thì tôi sẽ thử nói cho mấy ông ý nghĩa
của địa danh của của phố Hàng Đậu phố
nhà cũ của tôi đó là gì à
anh không mình không
Ừ mình ở chưa chuyên view lên mình chưa
dậy được với view
à à
đi theo mấy ông biết thì ở hành động à
ở Hà Nội có 36 phố phường đúng ạ thì mỗi
phố thường hay gắn à dụ phụ hàng này phố
hàng kia của ông Đào phố Hàng Khoai phụ
hàng gió Phân vân thì
theo mấy ông thì tại sao nó là tên là
hàng đậu
em không trả không chưa tra Google nha
thì tại sao ta tên là hành động
ông học tiếng Việt tại sao lại học được
tiếng
nghĩ thì đầu tiên đúng không Ừ hồi bé
rồi nghĩ thế
và mùi động
ở nhà Thực tế hàng đậu này nó lại khác
sau buổi rất nhiều cái hàng khác rồi cảm
thấy thế
hành động này nó tên là như thế bởi vì
nó là biến động Bến để mở rộng xe à
Không phải đậu thuyền đấy đấy à
ở chỗ ngồi hạt đậu gì cả à
Ừ đấy thì tại sao lại có khái niệm thế
bởi vì là giờ tôi sẽ cho người ông xem
Google Maps
không
a Red River lại không Sông Hồng đặt tên
Glass đấy Đê sông Hồng lúc nó về Hà Nội
rồi đúng không cái hành đậu Hàng Đậu này
Ừ rồi đấy à 36 Phường Đây này cái thằng
Đậu ở đây này tại hạt đậu này Đấy yêu
hồi đấy rồi đấy nhá cái á
ở sông hồng Nó không bé nhưng ở đâu con
lớn lắm nó sẽ đến Tít đoạn này Đấy sau
đó thì cái đường này cái đường đi phụ
này rồi đấy Nó sẽ phải nó phải xây cao
lên nó thành cái d kiểu gì mà chán chán
không cho nước của sông tràn vào đúng
không kiểu gì chả phải có D đúng không
đấy Nên là đây là cái cái tuyến phố cái
này nó vẫn còn được gọi là đê dưới d hội
trên D gì đó đấy hồi đấy cái cái cái d
và cái phố Hàng Đậu này lúc đấy Đó là
cái chỗ biết đâu của kiểu nói chung là
kiểu hải cảng có hư đấy
à không phải hại không đúng Hả biển vào
đúng
chỗ ở chỗ biến đậu thôi đấy
mỗi cái tên của cái địa danh thôi
Ê bà toàn bộ những cái vừa cái còn lại
tôi vừa nói tay chém gió
nếu mà Mấy ông vẫn thấy nghe về thuyết
phục đúng không Bởi vì tôi tự tự chém
tôi tự tôi
em gọi nhờ ạ
Ừ rồi áp dụng kiến thức của mình và tôi
cảm thấy rất siêu nặng thế nghe vẻ hợp
lý vừa chém ra nhưng mấy ông nghe vẫn có
về chứ phục đúng ạ em hết đúc kết của
câu chuyện vừa rồi nó là gì đó Khi ông
chỉ cần biết một tí kiến thức và ông cha
được vài cái trên Google mà người ta
chưa biết ông thể hoàn toàn chém gió
được rồi những người dân mà tri thức mà
kết hợp với cái sự tự tin
áo
kiểu dân nói cho người ta có kiến thức
cái nào kết hợp sự tự tin nữa người ta
hoàn toàn thể chém lừa rất nhiều người
khi mà người người ta tin sái cổ ạ Đấy
đấy là cách của một đa cấp mẹ ông nghe
vừa rồi nghe về bán bỏ Thế có phải có
phải đúng đúng bọn tôi không tin tôi
không biết là đúng hay sai nhưng tôi vừa
chém nữa mà
công ty đấy Không tin kệ em
về ông và đặc biệt là hãy cho em cái gì
mà nó chao Google có vẻ cũng không ra cơ
A Gấu trai kiểu gì phản điện tôi là sai
rồi
nó không thể chạm cái gì đó mình chỉ cần
có một tí kiến thức thôi Ở Mình chém có
lấy tôi từng đôi từng chỉ mấy ông cái
cách mà Hồi đấy tôi đi làm ba cấp rồi mà
đúng không nó sẽ học
từng nói rồi mà Thì phải
hai tôi có nhau lại nhớ cái hồi tôi học
một cái bài giáo án nghe để làm đa cấp
này à
ờ ờ Thời trước thời chiến tranh ờ
Chị Thơ chiến tranh thì 13
Em yêu giờ người đang nghèo đói không có
gì ăn không có tiền đúng không ạ sau
chiến tranh chi mà những người lính đi
trở về thì họ bắt đầu à
anh à lập gia đình họ có tiền bạc rồi họ
của cải rồi ông ạ thì lúc đấy Khi mà họ
có độ đầy đủ vật chất rồi chị họ lại già
rồi họ bây giờ họ rất cần cái thứ để mà
họ hồi xuân họ trẻ lại để sống với con
cháu bọn đấy thế hệ boomer so với các
thứ ấy
anh vào chúng tôi hôm nay đã tìm ra được
cái bí quyết để vợ là trường sinh bất
lão này hay gì đó lại để sản phẩm của
chúng tôi đã đúc kết kiểu đã đi khai
quật ở đâu đó đưa rõ về đây để phát minh
ra cái thuốc này thuốc này nó sẽ kiểu
nói Thực phẩm chức năng nó kiểu dạng
Nó là kiểu à
Ừ thôi đây nhờ bê không còn vẻ như hồi
đấy rồi đấy tôi văn vẻ lắm Tôi học thuộc
cái bài này
từ năm nhất ở không còn vẻ được như thế
nữa
chẳng có tài sản
Ừ ông không biết hơi này đến về giàu nhà
rồi thắng trận về lúc nào chẳng giàu
tôi không thuê đem đi tán gái tôi không
đi lừa ai cả
quê ấy thế nên tôi bảo ông vẫn phải có
kiến thức trong đầu tôi có bảo đâu Kiểu
chém gió xuống đâu không phải có kiến
thức trong đầu có kiến thức mà người ta
không có ấy đúng không cho ông chém về
vấn đề đấy như thật đấy Đã bảo đúng rồi
ta sẽ tin sái cổ ông thôi Nóng chém về
đúng kiến thức rồi đó Biết gì đấy Nó lỗi
của ông muốn gì con mắt thợ ở lỗ của ông
đúng ạ
rồi đó là mấy cũng phải biết mình biết
ta là không ạ dù là sử ở đây là tôi đang
dạy học cho bé ông ấy có thể Thậm chí
tôi đang loài mày đâu Mày cũng không
biết thì tôi khẳng định kiến thức của
tôi ở trong lĩnh vực này hiện tại Từ đó
hơn mấy ông ấy tôi nói cái gì Được đấy
Chẳng hạn đấy tôi bây giờ đi dạy những
cái người giỏi hơn tôi bạn nó dậy được
đúng không Nói hai câu bị và hai câu rồi
ấy Thế không Tôi sẽ chỉ đi yên lòng được
người người chưa biết gì thôi
phố Hàng Đậu bởi vì t là hàng đậu vì bán
nhiều loại đậu hạt đã đâu những tinh nhớ
chắc chắn là nó là Hà đậu vì nó biến
động mà
cái tôi từng tra rồi
nó bảo là xuất xứ từ
Ừ rồi chúng mình tra kiểu gì nó thành
biến động nghỉ lửa
bến đậu gì gì đó
điều tôi Mình nghĩ nó mới đúng
221 mà
Ừ thế thôi cha là từ năm nhất 52 để rồi
cha nói viết lại cái bài khác rồi Hoặc
là nó sửa sự bài cũ
Ừ nếu sao mình muốn chém gió lửa được
mọi người rồi quan tâm gì đâu
tôi không quan trọng nhưng được cái nữa
tôi nó vẫn ông kiến thức gì đó người ta
không biết người ta lên mạng người ra
Đình Chính thì đấy kia à
cho mà người ta ở không không lên mạng
để tra lại người đó tin sái cổ ông rồi
đi chia sẻ cho người khác đấy thì
Ừ thì uống giỏi một khi người ta đã tra
lại có nhiều thứ phản biện lại ông giống
thua rồi
em không thích nhỉ Tí xem lại rồi mà
thôi Anh thương chưa xem mà ạ
Khi bữa hôm nay mấy ông không hỏi gì á
không tâm sự gì à Vừa nãy đâu rồi Có vừa
nãy các bạn thì nhắc người yêu cũ để rửa
xe máy phát
ờ ờ
Xóa rồi
bị bơ xóa vậy
Ở đây Tình hình là em mới thấy người yêu
cũ công khai người yêu mới và thằng đó
là thằng Lúc trước em quen bảo là thằng
bạn thân
Ừ thì tôi đã từng nói mấy ông dổi mà làm
gì có khái niệm
về tình bạn giữa hai người khác giới con
gái để coi Đấy là bạn nhưng thậm chí
thằng con trai có thể gọi lại cho bạn
nhưng vì nó không nằm trong bốn cái
trường hợp tôi từng bảo nó là một là hai
đứa
ở cùng dẫn À nhầm hai đứa đều có vấn đề
về giới tính
ăn trộm vô tình hay thì gì đó nóng cho
đại khái vấn đề gì Thứ Hai Là Đớn gái
chưa ai nhớ rồi là đứa con gái già xấu
Thái trai xấu đôi khi để vẫn đi uống
điện thoại con Chắc nhớ đỡ để xấu nữa
chị có trai không không không màng tới
xấu trong mẹ cháu vừa đó nhá
ba là gì à Đừng nói rất điên Tôi tưởng
bạn tôi từng 8
ở đây để bạn hiểu có vấn đề không phải
điên đâu có điên thần kinh rồi nhé mày
điên chuyển làn để cậu nó
cuồng Hằng sẻ hạn nó sẽ không để những
cái thằng trai thường như mình nhưng ạ
Nó cứ thần tượng mày ai rồi ạ Ông sẽ
không có tán được mấy bạn ơi đâu đấy Cái
44 là gì nhỉ Đúng rồi bố là khi mà cả
hai đều đang có người yêu còn rất yêu
người kia còn một trong bốn chừng không
nằm trong bốn trường hợp đấy thì
a hoàn toàn là vẫn có thể vẫn có thể
phát sinh tình cảm một giữa một trong
hai người
Vì một khi mà vẫn có thể thì vẫn có thể
xảy ra mà nói thì chị không khái niệm
tình bạn khác rồi Đâu Bây giờ là sử chia
tay xong thì đấy bạn đấy sẽ hiểu ra rồi
khóc lóc cái thằng kia Thằng kia lại
muốn kiểu che cho ở bạn đấy các thứ xong
rồi sẽ chở bằng nhiều yếu tố mà
đặc biệt là khi xuất tinh xong rồi Kiểu
gì thằng rủ nhau đi nhậu đi nhậu xong có
tí men lên nữa Chán dễ làm gì đó sai
trái tội lỗi rồi cảm thấy là cũng thích
thích khi mà làm những cái thứ sai trái
tội lỗi đấy người con người rất dễ bị
kích thích bởi đấy thôi công thì cứ tiến
tới thôi
cho tôi tôi chơi bị bị trường hợp đấy
tôi thấy trường hợp lý rồi lại nữa
con gái hơn tuổi nói chung ấy thì ở
trường hợp 1 là ông phải chín chắn hơn
bạn ấy bạn ấy thấy à ông chín chắn
anh theo kiểu gì ở ngưỡng mộ ngây sự
chín chắn đấy tôi tới tôi đã từng như
thế và tôi thấy khó có vẻ được còn
trường hợp thứ 2
ở đó là bạn đấy có
gọi nhà con sở thích có sở thích hơi bị
ở chủ động đó là thích chăm sóc người
khác giống như kiểu coi ông như em trai
thật chứ là dùng thử mẹ con cũng có tí
Đúng rồi sẽ thích chăm sóc ông chị ạ thì
ông sẽ không cần phải tỏ chín chắn ông
tỏ chị con trong mắt vào đấy
Ừ nhưng mà trẻ con thì dễ nhiều bạn cũng
làm được trẻ con giống ông nữa cứ nghĩ
là cái trường hợp mà chính Chán nhỉ ít
người giống ông thì ông khác biệt với
trẻ con nhiều đứa trẻ con lắm
Ừ nhưng mà nói chung là đại khái là là
đấy là một trong hai cái kiểu mà thấy
ông Táo người khác giới mà lớn tuổi hơn
tám bạn nữ lớn tuổi hơn một là ông giờ
chín chắn thì chắn hơn cả những bạn bằng
tuổi bạn đấy thì bạn ấy sẽ
anh cảm thấy ông có gì khác biệt
đó mà bạn ấy đã từng có em trai thì nó
sẽ bạn thích cả Chăm Sóc Em Trai tự
nhiên ông bạn sao giống như thế bạn
thích chăm sóc đâu đấy Đi nhau rồi
anh hả
Ừ cái gì thực tế là thằng con trai nào
khi mà có bạn gái đôi khi nó sẽ trẻ con
Yếu Đuối thôi ông Ông có muốn cậu đôi
khi là những cái lúc mà ông có phật gặp
gần đây về bác đấy Ông có muốn kiểu tựa
vào bờ bờ vai hyper gì gì đó của bạn đấy
mà
ở Châu Á cậu có Nghệ An ủi không vui mà
tượng hơi buồn
nó coi là bạn thân
Lại gì nữa
chứ tôi vợ say nỗi không không kiểm soát
được không Nếu mà sai không kiểm soát
được ông nôn sử ông ấy ở đấy rồi không
làm cái gì đâu
bói đúng 1 lần tao rủ anh ai người ta
nói tốt với mình khá nhiều nhưng tôi
không tin được đấy thôi Không mê tín
thôi muốn mọi thứ do mình quyết định
tán bằng cách là trưởng thành hơn thôi
cho tôi Toyota trưởng thành hơn so với
bằng lừa thì đúng
chi tiền mặt thì có thể non nhưng mà tôi
nghĩ là tôi chạy đồ nhiều hơn sau mấy
cái thằng bạn xung quanh em ạ Như bạn
xung quanh tôi cũng cần đánh
ô nhiễm trùng Tử Đồng Bông cũng đúng
anh có biết Facebook fanzone không chắc
bị fan tôm suốt mà không tán được bạn
nào đó thì bạn ơi con mình nhờ bạn thân
thôi
à à
thì hơi khó tôi đang định là tổ chức
offline ở Sài Gòn và có thể sẽ Nam sẽ Đà
Nẵng sau đó nữa thì chắc lại Hà Nội còn
ở Cần Thơ thì ở
ở đây là người đầu tiên Nhắc tôi vụ Cần
Thơ đấy Tôi cũng không biết rồi Ở đây có
mấy người chưa bao giờ vào đây
Em không biết thế nào luôn à
mới gặp mà mình thích ạ Ừ ừ
cái nói chung đó là
không nên để mấy bạn nữ biết được là
mình thích các bạn đấy Nên là một bảo
ông rất dẻo mum theo kiểu là mấy ông cậu
đẹp trai già mồm ở trên mấy cái video
tối thường anh xem chạy ra tán gái lạ ấy
thì không biết được tỉ lệ cũng như nào
ngờ bé ông ấy tự tin lắm mà tôi nghĩ em
yêu không tạt được cái cảnh cảnh người
đâu Tôi cần xả đạt được những cái dở đấy
hợp được cả Tán phải em có người yêu rồi
thì mệt lắm nên là
Ừ cái đơn giản nhất thì đó là hãy xuyến
cho bạn ấy nghĩ ra là mình không hoàn
toàn chủ động với những bạn đấy Đó là
một cái tình cờ vì đó ví dụ điển hình
giống như là
địa hình đó là ông nên đi cùng với thằng
bạn thì tốt thằng bạn nó gọi đến Tây nữa
gọi là winmend nữa là trộn trợ thủ đắc
lực cái kiểu thế cho thủ ở đây trong
việc thanh gái là cái gì ông đi cùng
thằng bạn từ cả hai cực hay hỏi chẳng
cần nói gì về nhau đâu Thế bạn nào cậu
có vẻ hợp mình khi mà chạy ra xin số
theo kiểu là bảo là thằng bạn anh vừa
Anh vừa chơi cho cá thằng bạn nó sai anh
xin được số của em hãy em thể cho anh số
được không em một cái đơn giản thì thôi
ờ ờ
cũng sẽ không thích kiểu đấy nhưng mà
tôi đang chỉ ví dụ một cái trường hợp để
mà đó là ông không hẳn là một con người
chủ động trong việc là
kiểu tiến tới bạn đấy còn nếu mà ông chủ
động tiến thì phải là bạn đấy thấy ưng
ông rồi hoặc cả tùy ý đến ông trước rồi
thì lúc này ông ấy Tiến ta sự là kéo ở
trong quán cà phê và cả chậm gì À cậu
như trong phim được là đi 3 bùng các thứ
thứ
đi khỏi Bà nhảy em nhé 13 rồi cậu ba nhà
ca sĩ ung thư
Ê mấy ông mấy ông không biết thì có khái
niệm này tôi sẽ khai sáng với ông ấy
ở đó là kiểu dáng nó cái này mới chuẩn
là cái ba này ba này là ba cửa Nghe nhạc
uống kiểu uống rượu tây hay uống gì đó
Đấy cái này nó nhẹ thôi và cốc à Người
ta đến đây để tránh ù nào ra để đây cốt
để mà thư giãn Nghe nhạc và cậu chịu gọi
thoải mái
ở đấy và những người đến đây là những
người cũng
có tí tiền phải dùng từ có tính tiền mà
chẳng đứa sinh viên này đây cả
như là đang nói là là kiểu giật sự đến ở
những cái quán như thế này người đã để ý
mấy ông đã nhìn thấy nhìn ông mấy lần
liền này thì cũng phải biết ý Thì lúc
này ông có thể chủ động ra nói chuyện
với ta một cái thoải mái thôi không sao
cả
Thơ này
đến tháng 10 cơ tháng tháng 10 tháng à
tháng 8 mua sẽ tạo form đăng ký
Em ở quận mấy tuổi sẽ cố hạn chế để xa
lắm
à Cậu Cân gần và nói chung mà còn phải
chọn quán đủ sức chứa nữa
ở Đà Nẵng thì bảo rồi Sang năm nhé
cho đầu năm thôi
người vừa trải có khác đi
Ừ bắt chuyện với con gái chỉ cần thấy
bạn ấy có vẻ ổn Nói chung là thời gian
với ông cứ nghĩ gì đó phức tạp làm gì
nếu mà bạn ấy thực sự nửa kia của mình
thì nói chuyện gì với bạn đấy cũng sẽ
hợp thôi kể cả ông đùa rất ở nhà mà bạn
ấy cười thì đang ghi điểm rồi trừ khi ở
ông đang mặc bộ gì đã ông đã mặc một bộ
tầm trăm triệu yêu cậu là Gucci có hư
cái gì ở ông chỉ còn sợ ra Bạn hãy thấy
vui rồi là thế hơi quá Nhưng mà nhìn đại
khá à ý là bạn đấy mà thấy thích ông rồi
thì à bạn các bạn nữ Tinh Nghi lắm thế
này như là ông bà tiếp cận ngoài đời thì
cái độ tâm lý của bạn ấy còn cao hơn nữa
nha ông không còn bộc lộ nhiều đâu
lừa con gái khác đâu mà cần phải cậu
Có phải rất là chuyên nghiệp trong cái
khóa mày ông phải Chuyên Gia Chăn Rau
đâu không ạ nên là tôi nghĩ à thoải mái
thôi
chuyện với bạn
chứ không phải một bạn đã 23 Bạn gì ở
từng nói Tôi
Em có cách nói chuyện của anh nó giống
như nhiều giống như vài bạn ở đây nói
cái nói chuyện anh giống kiểu tóc boy
là tôi không Tôi bảo rồi tao không phải
sex boy nhưng mà nhưng mà hiểu tôi chạy
quá nhiều ấy nếu là thành ra là
anh nói chuyện nó kiểu bị Cứ cho là
Em hiểu ý bạn ấy quá hay là chữ nghiệp
quá gì nó hiểu cũng lẻo mép quá có gì đó
khiến ơi bạn ấy cảm thấy lại à
không bạn các bạn gái thưởng ai giữa sở
thích cảm giác an toàn đó là chìa khóa
cho dạng là
Em an tâm khi mà yêu ông ấy áo tầm ở đây
rồi Ở đây thứ nhất ở cả cả ông thì xe
chở người khó thứ hai là ông sẽ không đi
tán đứa cái khác không yêu ai khác ngoài
bắt đấy Thanh Vân
cho nên thành ra là nhiều bạn con gái
thượng chị đã chọn những bạn có chai
hơi xấu tràn một tí nhưng mà cảm thấy
bạn lấy chung thủy còn hơn là mấy bạn
đẹp trai rồi lươn lẹo thì nghĩ rằng à
là mấy thằng đấy Kiểu gì cũng sẽ bỏ mình
người theo bạn nực bạn nữ khác thì ra là
cũng
quá rồi mày cái chuyện tình cảm đâu càng
nói lươn thì càng à
Hà Nội cho biết đổi giọng gì
có thể giống mic đấy Tôi tin là cái mic
này thay đổi giọng thôi cũng nghe các
bạn bảo là giọng nói ngọt hơn đúng không
để cho rằng con mix vọng tôi ngoài đời
không ngọt nhận tôi ngoài đời chậm hơn
nhà thôi nhà thôi và tôi đang ở Hà Nội
nhiều ý ông họ là vậy ạ
từ hôm nay quyết định để sẵn có nhóm hả
Buồn thế trạm tắt vậy
[âm nhạc]
Ngoài lúc dạy học là tội muôn kiểu tạo
là tâm sự chia sẻ với ông thôi và về cậu
sẽ chia sẻ vài quan điểm tôi nữa
xu hướng đến là như thế mà
nữa đúng con người mới chia tay cả hiểu
đời khấu đôi nhìn rõ vạn vật ờ ờ
có người phù hợp với mình nên là nói
chung và mấy ông không cần phải
lươn hay là giả vờ hay nói dối gì cả mà
em cứ thành thật thôi
Ừ đúng ạ à
A và kiểu
ở Mình hãy cứ thoải mái cứ tự nhiên các
giải chính mình nhưng mà cũng nên là
phiên bản tốt của mình chứ phải phiên
bản xấu của mình không phải lần đầu tiên
đi hẹn hò cả ông
áo kiểu chưa Chuẩn bị cái gì cả đó ông
kiểu giả nhà
đơn giản quá thì được là nó không hay
lắm có thể thao nói chung ở tù ấy bởi vì
à Bạn kia bạn kia phải như nào nữa và
sửa bạn kia cũng biết cũng rất lập quan
trọng cái
cái Buổi Hẹn Đầu tiên thì ông cũng phải
như thế
em còn nếu mà bạn kia giả và sự rất
suồng sã đỡ cậu thoải mái thì ông cũng
phải thoải mái ông đừng có gò bó quá
anh nói chung à chuyện tình cảm thì tôi
thấy gà Tôi là người rất thấp Bạn liên
tục chuyện tình cảm
khi nghe Tôi chỉ biết khuyên với ông hội
cho tôi không
anh cũng không à anh khẳng định được ở
nó đúng hoàn toàn
Tôi khuyên được mấy ông đó là à
khi sex
ờ ờ
ông không nên Tiến hoàn toàn ví dụ là
tôi thường ai có câu đó là giả sử khoảng
cách giữa anh với em là 1.000 bước đúng
ạ
Ừ thì ít nhất là em phải bước cái đầu
tiên đã sao anh hãy bước cái 99 999 bước
còn lại chứ nếu mà giả sử mà ông đòi
bước một nghìn bước gửi cho bạn không
bước bước nào ý thứ không bạn đầy thấy
ông kiểu áo kiểu chạy đến họ bước như
thế họ chạy đi đấy ngày tận thế tức làm
sao ạ Mấy ông không phải vồ vập dồn dập
quá mà ông cũng phải để cho các bạn đấy
á
ở khoảng cách này kết hợp việc cả phải
cho mấy bạn ấy chủ động một ít Đã mời
ông chủ động sao
Tôi chưa học học xong đại học tôi đã
hoặc bên hông cho học à
từ hôm trước tôi phải biết cái nốt gì
hết là tôi cũng đang ngồi cốt view là
bản chất nó nuốt hết đấy nhưng mà tôi sẽ
không dại đâu
khi lần đầu đi hẹn hò thì mình nên làm
gì cho ngầu ạ
là đầu đi hẹn hò thì tôi khi em bé ông
đừng có đi xem phim nữa vậy chẳng nói
chuyện thì nhau mấy đâu Và thậm chí xấu
xa nhau các thứ thứ
Heaven không lành mạnh lắm Ờ
ở đâu đi hẹn hò thì mấy ông nên cậu ăn
uống kết hợp với đi cà phê lớn nhất bởi
vì ông nha
Ừ nếu bé Ông Bỉ kỹ thì đi đi ăn thì con
gái nhất là đường và dạ dày họ sẽ
Cho đường vào tim và đường vào dạ dày
Nếu mà Mấy ông nói không đủ ngọt đấy
nhất thứ hai là mấy ông Để ý kỹ những
cái mọi thứ khi bạn để làm khi ăn đấy từ
việc ạ là Lau mắt lau đũa này hay là gọi
món thấy Vân này rất nhiều cái tinh nhỉ
ông đấy trong một bữa ăn
và có thể bạn ấy cẩn thận lúc đấy nhưng
nghĩa là bạn đấy có thể giả tạo lúc đấy
cũng có thể đúng nhưng mà hãy để ý kĩ
một vài chi tiết thì đó
tiếp theo là đi uống nước nữa
em ở chỗ mấy ông nhớ được những cái sở
thích lúc lúc đấy của bạn đấy tốt bãi sẽ
thường ai cố gọi những cái gì đó đơn
giản và thoải mái với bạn đấy
ờ ờ
ai và vì sao mà bận về sau ông nhớ những
cái đấy nhá và và vài buổi hẹn sau ấy mà
ông có thể mua cho bạn có thể gọi cho
bạn ấy
em gọi hộ bạn đấy rồi đấy bảo là anh sẽ
thấy hay đấy
và đặc biệt à tôi biết khá nhiều quán ăn
hoặc là ăn thôi
cho hai kẻ ăn người giờ tôi phải ăn quán
nào Có vẻ ngon ngon rồi mới ăn đấy
số người tham gia là nhiều bạn nữ cũng
thích có cảm tình với tôi để tôi biết
khá nhiều quán ngon cho chị nhiều cũ còn
dẫn
nhiều cũ dẫn nhiều người đến quán của
tôi đậu xanh
à à
chuyện chị infor gái đi ha
ờ ờ
Ý tôi là tôi chưa bắt chuyện ngoài đời
để mà xin các bạn bạn nữ mấy để tán tỉnh
mấy
Ừ tại vì vẫn dễ dính Bạn có nhiều khắc
này là tôi không ý định này lắm sao tự
nhiên là chuyện đâu đấy mấy ông xem
Seagame xong rồi à
đột cãi nhau còn lại quá không
có chứa ở tôi biết có rất nhiều cặp đó
là cãi nhau suốt họ vẫn bền để họ biết
cách giải quyết rõ nhiều cặp thì yêu
nhau rất là lâu không được có vấn đề mà
tội Hi vọng các bạn sẽ không về vấn đề
bởi một khi có vấn đề mà các bạn sẽ
quyết mà không một cái các bạn lại người
chia tay ra rễ
từ một cái chi tiết nhỏ thôi nhưng mà
Bởi vì từ trước này là quá hoàn hảo rồi
nếu các bạn không biết cách giải quyết
vấn đề
Em không biết cái giải quyết mâu thuẫn
ấy nghe nó nó lại đi ra tệ này
lập gia đình ạ a ý ông 27 30 mới bắt đầu
yêu quá hay là như thế nào nhỉ
chưa hiểu ý bạn lắm nhưng mà
tôi không quan trọng với tuổi tác khi mà
hẹn hò ba đội yêu ông Thể Yêu Muộn yêu
sớm tùy nhà đương nhiên là sẽ có người
khác phán xét ông người điều đấy Ở sự
tại sao ông yêu Sơn Thế tại sao không
như bọn hết đồ kiểu ông ạ
em có bỏ qua được cái đấy Ông thấy thoải
mái không Đã lấy cái đầu tiên ông phải
tự hỏi chính ông rồi đúng
anh bởi vì chị mà ông hỏi câu đấy đã bạn
hơn cũng thấy có tính vấn đề gì thôi ông
ạ Còn tôi tôi không thấy có vấn đề thì
vấn đề đấy cả tùy mấy ông quan điểm nữa
mà
khi bạn mua khi ông trả lời được và ông
còn giải thích được cho người khác là nó
chẳng có vấn đề gì cả thì nó sẽ vấn đề
gì à Ông con nó bình thường thì mọi
người sẽ dần dần lại coi nó bình thường
à
khi bé Ông định lấy quán của tôi á mày
không lấy danh sách quán của tôi tôi hết
chỗ giảm cái
không phải đưa thế Nhưng mà thực ra là
thứ các bạn nữ giờ Nói chung mình thử
gái thích ăn phải sạc thôi hải sản ấy ra
tôi có lại ít quán Còn mấy ông Thế thì
chủ yếu là quán ăn con vặt này á Nhưng
mà Buổi Hẹn Đầu Không ăn vặt
Ừ nhưng mà tôi khuya đấy Đó là
đừng có dẫn mở quán ăn nha
khoa học đường dẫn KFC ở Lotte thời sự
đừng có hẹn hò buổi đầu tiên ở dẫn vào
KFC Lotte
thật đấy mình không thể dẫn bất kỳ quán
nào mùa quán gấu Ông cảm thấy à sang
trọng cũng được Hay quán kiểu dạng nhà
nó kiểu Dạ ở sinh viên cũng được với ông
sinh viên mà đấy á Không ngờ ông sinh
viên mình dẫn nó có sinh viên nhé hoặc
là dẫn mà quá mà ông khai ăn thôi Ông
cảm thấy là của ông thân thuộc ông Thiện
giới thiệu qua để quán Anh hai ăn gì đó
không sao cả không thì bảo bạn đã đi
suốt thôi không sao
ha ha
thế nhưng nhấn mạnh lại không dẫn bảo
quản ăn ngay sự có sao gặp xe nó tê hẹn
kinh kiểu gì à
đề con gì
Ừ ông ấy dẫn đi ăn à
Em mua ở nhà hàng hay mới còn lậu cũng
được không sao như còn lẩu tùy quán nhà
nhiều quá Thôi ăn thấy rõ chán Không
biết mày không thể nào
sự thật là chính xác ở tôi bắt đầu hẹn
hò nhiều từ năm nhất đại học còn hồi năm
cấp 2 cấp 3 tôi còn yêu đơn phương thôi
ăn thì à
ừ ừ
nhà thì
nói thẳng thế họ ông phải nói khéo lắm
thì họ mới về chắc chắn là họ nghĩ à ông
ạ nỡ ăn của ông Xong ông ăn bạn đấy sao
đây
là ông có thể
rủ nếu mà ông vẫn muốn tận dụng cái tài
nấu ăn của ông ấy thì ông nên Rủ đi
picnic ở
ờ ờ sau đó nó mang đồ ăn đi
cho nên thế nên thế
cho nó dễ nói suy nghĩ linh tinh lắm
thật sự đấy
từ trước khi ở nhà ông dầu khác giống
dầu rồi ông bà
cho anh một mình một cái biệt thự này
anh thấy cô đơn đó em muốn về xem cái đó
tủ bếp nhà anh to nghèo anh nấu cho
Hoàng Anh có người anh nấu cho nhé sợ
anh sẽ có một phòng chữa ngồi xem phim
hai đứa sẽ xin lắm à phòng à Cậu xem
phim full HD Cinema Hà gì ai mắc ở trong
đấy đi dù cả loa dàn loa xịn đấy
ở sông ấy xong em mình có thể tắm luôn
bể bơi cá thư
Nếu thế thì nó thì đa số các bạn gái sẽ
đồng ý
anh ta số
ổn rồi cho lần trước thì thấy à mình xin
cái driver của Mike ngày tự nhiên chết
đông không
ờ ờ
chuyên ứng biến nè cũng không biết
khuyên về ông như thế nào về cái khoản
là thuyết trình hay cá thứ tôi tròn
chuẩn bị gì cả đặc biệt là trước khi dạy
hay tội chảnh chuẩn bị tài liệu hơn gì
cả tôi vẫn như vậy thôi
ông có tâm lý là thứ mấy ông có nghĩa là
chẳng nên cần phải nhìn mặt ai cả mà ông
Cư nói và nhìn ở chỗ nào xăm rồi ông cần
chú ý vẻ mặt của ai cả
A và
3 cách thuyết trình chuẩn đó mấy ông Hạn
chế
bị dập cuộn tôi tôi lại Nếu mà bây giờ
bác Tôi cần một đống tờ giấy rồi bắt tôi
đọc cái khuôn mỗi bắt tôi phải nói đúng
đấy Tôi không nói được không Tôi sẽ muốn
đấy cho tôi thích ứng biến đó tao không
thích kiểu Rập khuôn nói cái gì đó vì có
thể tôi sẽ quên em hãy ra tôi sẽ chỉ như
ý chí nhưng mà tôi sẽ nói liên quan theo
cái ý chính đấy
Ừ thì tôi sẽ nói được mấy ông có thể lên
thế Và thậm chí ở Tôi không tập trước
của tôi tập trước có khi mà
ở đô thị Ông tập trước thì ông sẽ
anh có thể nó ra hay đấy Sau đó lúc mà
nói thực tế thì ông ngoại không cảm thấy
không giống như ông lúc ông tập hoặc gà
ông sẽ bị bất tử thì gì đó thì nói loạn
lên ngọn tới tôi con điểm như thế còn à
khi còn đương nhiên là mấy ông một chút
trình hai ông phải chứ chị nhiều rồi cho
chả nội quy trình trước một vài bạn bè
trước rồi để mà quen dần thôi đã để
người ta góp ý yêu mình đã sử thứ và
người ta cũng động viên mình em mình bớt
tâm lý nữa
buổi hẹn lần đầu và em nói chuyện với
bạn bạn ấy nhiều hơn nhất là nếu mà hẹn
hò thì đi hai người như thế thì tôi
không tỉnh em một buổi hẹn họ tôi không
Thế thôi không biết ông tình thế không
nhưng mà bạn kia thì thôi
ý nghĩa bạn ấy cũng Run hay gì đó nhưng
nói chung là đại khái thì tôi không tình
đấy buổi hẹn hò
Anh ta nói chuyện thì ông đang nghĩ rằng
là ông nói chuyện với bạn bạn ấy nhiều
hơn thì
ông thích bạn bạn đấy hơn hay là do Hôm
đấy ông Ngại hay gì đó nghĩa là nếu mà
tôi như là sửa bạn đấy Có nó lại về tôi
ở tại sao hôm đấy anh nói chuyện với bạn
khi nhiều hơn thì tôi hoàn toàn nền văn
vở lại kiểu Anh muốn thấy tình cảm với
bạn của em thôi Kiều
anh Bởi vì à thời gian thì nói nhỉ Bạn
của các bạn nữ lại ảnh hưởng khá nhiều
ở trong mối quan hệ thứ là nó cũng hơi
bị rủi ro một tí Bởi vì nếu nữa bạn đấy
mà thích ông thì cậu gì có vấn đề còn
nếu đứa bạn đấy mà ghét ông gì còn vấn
đề
xúc nhiều với bạn của bạn ấy kể cả trong
tù à lành mạnh hay không chứ không
em về bạn ấy thích ông chỗ dịch phá
hiệu ngứa mắt đi em tải chung thì hơi bị
thế tôi nói chung ơi nhá tôi không Tôi
không ạ khẳng định tất cả nhưng mà
để thuận tiện ở chỗ là mấy ông biết mà
đi
a Mac studio
ý không Mà sao cái là màn hình của máy
Nhiều mà bạn của bạn đấy chúng ta nhiều
thì chứng tỏ bạn đấy Hôm đấy đi ngại rồi
như bạn đấy mới rủ thêm bạn nữa không
sao cả
Nói chung nhà em có có chủ động nói
chuyện bạn đấy nhưng mà bạn kia trả lời
cũng được không sao không sao cả giờ ra
thì ở
Anh đối với tôi Thì đấy vẫn đâu phải hẹn
hò đúng Ông có cần phải thế hạnh hóa cái
cái tình cảm hôm đấy sẽ chẳng có cái gì
cả gần đưa buổi phỏng vấn thì có một
người chở phiên dịch hội phiên dịch thôi
chứ không phải phỏng vấn thì
Ừ ông phải làm sao cho bạn đấy cảm thấy
bớt ngại bữa thoải mái hơn
anh nghe Thế sao bạn ghi hướng nội
Ừ cái đấy thì ta không phải khó đâu Bạn
ấy đã chủ bạn đấy đã dám đi đã là có một
cái gì đó rồi nhưng mà ông khiến nó bạn
ấy Mợ lời hơn được mở lòng như được thì
ông sẽ ghi điểm thôi Bởi vì à
Nói chung là khó 8 thì sẽ
chị sẽ không có gì sai cả khó tán thì sẽ
khi mà một khi tán được rồi thì cũng sẽ
chị sẽ ổn hơn dễ dễ tán thì con với có
vấn đề mấy ông ạ Để ông thử tán bạn nào
đó rồi lại vừa vào bông Xem ông sẽ nghĩ
là có vấn đề không đúng ạ
ừ
một tiếng 40 phút rồi mà chẳng còn nhiều
phết
số lượt xem bắt đầu giảm thôi chả hết
chủ đề nói luôn mấy ông kia sẽ ghét tôi
rồi buổi hôm nay chắc thế thôi nghỉ nói
thêm nhiều nữa khản giọng mất
theo bữa hôm nay tại thế
ờ ờ
Nếu không còn hỏi thắc mắc gì tâm sự gì
nữa không Chúng ta đã kết thúc đấy nhá á
bữa hôm nay không không có mục đích để
khoa học tập gì đâu để tham khảo chủ yếu
rồi tí thì tuổi xóa video định được
hôm nay không có một cái gì đó để mà Mấy
ông ah
à Cậu ra quy quy trách nhiệm của tôi anh
ạ Nói chung video này chị mục đích tham
khảo nhé
Chào mấy ông